Michael I understand from stalking you
online a little bit yes yes that a
British film director discovered you
while you were still in med school I was
in dental school at the time discovered
that's a very funny word isn't it we met
I was in at my favorite restaurant in
New York called Lucky Strike it was
actually under the apartment that I end
up living at in Manhattan down on Grand
Street was having brunch with my
girlfriend at the time
punch axes ago yeah and he's like oh are
you an actor I'm like no I'm actually
the student trying to start a career in
dentistry and he was like why I'm a
director and I've got a part in my film
that I think he'd be right for and as
soon as I heard that I'm like listen man
like I'm from New York like I I hear
crap all the time it's like whatever you
know so I really think anything of it I
looked him up he was actually legit film
director and working you know for like
20 years to be do big feature films so I
I called him and I I ended up working
with him personally for like a month or
two months rehearsing for this role I
didn't get the role but during that
two-month period when I was working with
him and I was like I I like this I
really enjoy acting and I was like I'm
gonna I'm gonna try this out so I talked
my parents about moving to New York and
it just I didn't look back I'd stopped
going to school and I started booking
stuff and I yeah it worked out what was
that conversation like cuz I've heard
others like from like comedian Brian
Regan and things like that he was in his
last year in college and he was going to
be an accountant or somebody like that
and they had to give that conversation
mom dad asked me I tell you
my parents have always been supportive
of me no matter what right but the one
thing was education you get your degree
no matter what and I had my bachelor
degree I went to Hamilton College and
got my degree in biology and that was
all great but they are both
professionals my father's a doctor my
mother's a nurse so you know you're
going to be a profession
because we are professionals and this is
what we want for you when we want you to
be secure and we want you to make a lot
of money that's not they said to me but
yeah they just they worry right parents
worry they want you to be stable and
have what they didn't have you know but
I told them you know I just want to try
this out like I don't I just
I'm young I I have a liking to this and
I think that I can do it and I like it
and I want to try it and I'm gonna move
to New York now and they were very
reluctant at first and it wasn't until
they started seeing me on television in
commercials or you know TV shows or
whatever and they were like okay so
you're not homeless
because he's only worried they worried
you know that in their mind an actor was
someone who would go to auditions and
just fail and they thought I was an end
up like in a gutter somewhere probably
but you know there is a smart boy I
wasn't an idiot oh yeah you know I could
hustle like you know I waited tables and
I was able to make my rent every every
month and the rule was this I said
here's the deal the day I asked you for
money or the day I asked you for your
help where I'm really struggling I can't
do any more on my own this is the day I
quit and I go back to school and I've
never asked them for anything so haven't
had to ask them for anything yet so it's
uh yeah and hopefully I won't have to if
you were gonna sit down another actor
who maybe was on a path to do something
else and their parents they were gonna
go meet their parents that weekend and
have that quote unquote talk yeah what
would you tell them what would be your
advice to that person you live once and
you don't have that much time on this
earth if there's something you really
want to do I mean really want to do like
there's nothing else you can do except
for this and it makes you that happy you
have to do it and and I think that's
important for us you know I think
there's a lot of people who are unhappy
in this world because they're doing
things they don't like to do and yes
they're probably financially secure but
they might be miserable is that really
how you want to live the rest of your
life I don't know for me I I couldn't do
that I'm too much
don't you stubborn for that so that
would be part of the talk if you were
gonna advise jack or Jill you know
blossoming artists yeah would that be
part of it too likes it mom and dad down
yeah I just think you have to be honest
with yourself and with them tell them
what you want to do now I want to do
this on my own
I took the hard route I didn't ask for
anything I didn't say you know can you
finance my apartment can you pay for
acting classes can you pay for this I
didn't ask for any of that because
because I want it to be on me this is my
choice
I'm leaving a lucrative career in
dentistry or medicine where you know I
did get a degree in biology you raised
me to be a doctor to be a professional
and I chose a different route but I
won't ask you for anything I'll do it on
my own you know it that's I think it's
easier for me to do that than to say I'm
gonna I'm gonna choose this career and
acting and to be an artist but you can
you pay for it that's a harder
conversation but I think I kind of put
pressure on them because I wasn't asking
them for anything
so it wasn't manipulative but it was
like this is my choice I love you and
you're my parents but I'm gonna do
something different than what you're
doing but that's okay I still love you
and you love me and we're and you're
still gonna be my parents and I'm still
gonna support you you're still gonna
support me but this is what I want to do
let's see what happens you know and it's
been fine they absolutely love it now
and they support me and they're like my
biggest fans my only fans that's like
you followed up though with action
absolutely probably the Keith well yeah
I went to New York and I was like all
right acting let's go learn how to act
so I went to Terry Schreiber I took
class to cherish our studio for years I
got into every class I could I started
signing up for student projects then
independent projects and then I got an
agent and a manager and you know Here I
am today do you put a lot of pressure on
yourself to make things happen it sounds
like you're probably a doer I get that
you have to do
there's too many actors in this business
too many good actors in this business
too many bad actors in this business to
not do your best every day I try and do
something there's another audition or
opportunity coming up what can I do to
better my career whether it's updating a
website whether it's taking on their
class whether it's go work on a scene
where something to do that's creative
that will help me because you have to be
constantly getting better you're not
getting better you're getting worse
right it's like oh it was a big a big
soccer player in college and in high
school and my philosophy was you're only
as good as your last game you're only as
good as your last practice right it's
very a sweets mentality so for acting
you're only as good as your last
audition or your last you know film you
can have an amazing movie but let's say
you do another film or a TV show where
the bombs and and you know you're not
getting good reaction or get traction
guess what that's the last impression
you can leave new people so you got to
bounce back you know so you have to be
constantly getting better my goal is to
try and be doing something every single
day creatively it's hard that's the
hardest thing about acting is that the
jobs there's not an audition every day
you're not going to work every day
steadily until you're at that level so
what do you want to write you want to
try into your own own projects that's
the that that's the goal for me since
that day that you had to talk with your
parents and you decided to take that you
know course change from being a dentist
to now acting have you ever thought back
about it no never never it's never
crossed your mind you know there were a
couple times I remember was waiting
tables it was okay it was in the middle
of a double and I had people like
throwing things at me it's just it can
see sometimes waiting tables can be a
terrible miserable job and even then I
was like should I should I just stop
right now stop what I'm doing and go
back and then and I was thinking about
dental school and how much that kind of
is terrible I was like now I could do a
people throwing talk wasn't me you know
I'll throw them back it's just like I
use that energy sometimes when it gets
really bad and I and I almost throw it
right back at people where I put into an
audition or I put into a you know you
know character that I'm working on and
that I kind of you know eases the pain
sometimes when you're going through
rough times and there are they're
absolutely edges and flows in a career
you know sometimes you're you're working
every single day for five six months
sometimes you can't get
it's it's crazy so since you have that
athletes mentality
do you have an ability to say okay I'm
now taking off my apron or my nametag or
whatever that Michael is done that's
just a role I play and now I'm going
back to my real life and then what do
you do to get yourself back on track
because I've had those jobs to work
you're just so down about what just
happened you have to do things that make
you happy when it's not in terms of
acting you have to go for me play soccer
if you like running I hate running but
some people like to run run run run run
you don't have an audition that week run
go do things to distract yourself that
make you happy but also better yourself
running athletics these are all good
things they keep you in shape right if
you like the party party but that's
where you can get into trouble because
people get caught up in that and then
they're not actors anymore they're just
people who pretend to be actors who are
just partying all day and trying to
network do you see that a lot I don't go
out anymore
I am completely focused on what's going
on in LA since I moved here I don't
really go out I go out it's you know
with with friends or people I like to
hang out with like a closed circle and I
really drink because it's that's
something that doesn't really help me
anymore I did enough drinking in New
York you know party a lot in New York so
it's here it's in LA for me it's work
and being an artist and just bettering
yourself as an actor do you remember the
day that you had that decision because
that's an amazing epiphany especially
being young handsome I'm sure there's
all these opportunities you get a lot of
attention when you go out but then there
is a flip side and then years can be
wasted when I got here I realized what I
was up against I got here what about a
year ago and I saw how many actors were
here in New York I knew there were a lot
of actors you know and you're competing
with all those actors but here you're
competing with probably 10 times the
amount of actors so what's your edge
right you have to ask yourself how am I
better than these people what's gonna
make me stand out you have to look
better you have to be a better actor you
have to be everything and what is
drinking really good - for me that
completely goes against
everything that I was doing so I was
starting out of the gym I started to
research more classes I started to
surround myself with artists I joined a
theater company and that's how it
actually did that play trust which got
some pretty good reviews in LA Weekly
recently so that that was a success
because it was like I didn't have any
auditions going on
go take go join a theater company and
good things came out of that so it's
just constantly finding ways to better
your career and going out and partying
it doesn't really do much for me anymore
when you came out here what was your
plan did with LA I mean you talked about
earlier getting a reel together okay
I've been trying to come to LA for four
years
actually before I actually moved here
money was the issue and then I booked a
couple commercials and I was blessed and
was very grateful that I booked them I
took the money invested it and then I
was able to move out here and I got here
and I didn't know anyone out here and it
was like okay talk to some people what's
this what do I do like you need to get a
manager and I'm not gonna go into out
I'm not gonna go into how I got one but
I hustled and I was able to take a bunch
of meetings and was able to gratefully
sign with a really solid manager which
then got me an agent and that happened
only about three or four months after I
got here so very lucky but he was all
planned he was all like I'm gonna move
to LA with my real with a website with
some credits with some heat and do this
I did it the right way
when I first moved when I was first
thinking and moving out here four years
ago I didn't have enough on my resume I
didn't I wasn't a good enough actor back
then and I knew that and I was like I'm
not gonna go to LA flounder around for
five years and just be another number
I'm gonna go there and show people stuff
and that's that's how it all went down
and that's why gratefully I'm
represented now so I can get having
other people work for me to get work
where were you when you got the call or
the information about this suppose at
auditions
this Duracell Powermat with cheese oh
man it was that house casting in New
York down in the West Village and I had
an audition for this commercial Duracell
Powermat commercial featuring jay-z
I went to the first audition and it was
just me you know with the cast director
going over this scene where I hand him
the phone there's some type of awkward
moment that happens I was like a sweet
audition I'll never get it just cuz it
didn't seem like it was my type I saw
the other other actors in the room and
and it just didn't seem like I don't
know I just did I didn't feel like I was
gonna get this role you know it
it's weird some it's weird how sometimes
you feel that and then those are the
ones of your book it's crazy I get a
call and like you got a callback for the
duracell I'm like okay cool my agent you
know called me I went back and there was
anthony mandler anthony mandler is one
of the biggest music video and creative
directors in business in Los Angeles he
shot all of Katy Perry's music video
music videos a lot of Lana Del Rey and
raised musically years I had no idea who
this guy was but he had the he sits
there interviews me and the callback
went well and I got a call like the next
thing like you booked to her cell and I
didn't really hit me until I was on set
you know like a week later and jay-z is
there in the room and we're doing scene
together I was I was like what you know
don't get starstruck I really don't I
see actors a lot and you know you meet a
lot of celebrities out here in New York
but jay-z is a force man that guy is
just I mean who wouldn't want to be
jay-z music clothes I mean he just he
owns a basketball team the guy who was
the man I was a little star-struck but
he was really cool talk to me like a
normal dude
and that's what I think's great about
him he's humble but I was thinking later
I mean he can be humble he doesn't have
a worry in the world he's married to a
beautiful well you know a beautiful girl
we don't Alton girls all the money it's
like why does he have to he doesn't need
to be you know conceited or cocky at all
because he's got it you know just the
charming awesome guy very grateful and I
took I was able to take the money from I
that I made from
those commercials and was able to move
to Los Angeles so and you realize how
much money you can make from these
national commercials they're pretty
awesome so hopefully I booked another
one soon they weren't a buyout what no
no no most most national network side
Union commercials are not buyouts so do
you remember being on set like how many
hours and oh yeah we shot the whole day
the commercial it's funny jay-z's only
in about three or four seconds of the
commercial I'm in like like three
quarters of it which is crazy
basically just a camera following me
around the city with my cool Powermat
charger you know being cool and you know
sending texts and being a city guy I
think they had me being like graphic
designer they had me in these cool
clothes
I still have clothes from that shoot I
still wear them because that was the
epitome of me being cool and they let me
keep some of the clothes I still rock
some of those outfits but they followed
me around New York and then we get to
the club and the whole scenario is I
accidentally pick up jay-z's phone I
pick it up and it says B is calling him
like B and then jay-z comes in he's like
I'm like oh very funny
awkward Roman in the commercial did well
and yeah it was cool to say that I was
in that it was really grateful to be in
it so do people recognize you um a few
people not not many because they're you
know they're paying attention to jay-z
it's not like when you're watching the
commercial like who's this guy
and then they see GG it's like Oh
jay-z's in that commercial they're not
really remembering the guy that's
handing the phone but you are in like
you said there's good three quarters oh
yeah that's awesome but jay-z Michael
Galante if I have one 90th of his power
and force you know that the height of my
career I will die happy man Michael you
said you weren't going to come to LA
until you had that acting real yeah
there were a few things that I made a
list of things I needed before I went to
LA one was a better resume
so I wasn't got some credits to was an
acting real because I knew how many
actors were out here I didn't know
exactly how many actors were out here
but I knew that there were a lot more
than New York
so I was in my mind I was like how am I
gonna stand out amongst this whole sea
of actors beginners advanced you know
whatever how am I going to stick out and
be noticed by a manager and agency well
get a real make a real make a highlight
tape of stuff you've done so you can
show people because guess what a
headshot is a headshot it's a picture of
you I could you know you could take a
picture of some guy walking down the
street called a headshot and he can say
I'm an actor sag after he'd be lie and
say it doesn't really do much unless you
look like Brad Pitt you know I don't
look like Brad Pitt so how do I
differentiate myself I have to show my
acting talent how do you do that invite
people to a show yeah are people gonna
come with them probably not maybe you
know maybe you get lucky you get you
know maybe out of 20 emails you send a
cast directors who want to come to your
your showcase maybe you get one that
comes but how can I effectively send out
a package with all my stuff in it that
everyone will at least have the access
to not necessarily click on cuz you get
spam on every day you can just get an
email from someone oh I mean this thing
okay delete but what if you package it
with a real a resume a website and all
your contact information and your
pictures on one web page what if you do
that so the goal was make a website have
you real on it have your photos have
news like a news feed of what stuff
you're doing to say hey Here I am here's
all my stuff take it or leave it and I
was gonna and I did that literally the
day before I left LA I had launched my
website and I did that on purpose to
just have a what do they call it like a
Bharat and on a barrage but have a I
don't know the word like a day and day
of you coming out there yeah exactly but
they have like just like um I'm not fine
the word but just I wanted to make it an
all-in-one
assault almost like an assault of
Michael Galante not bits and pieces not
you know it's all who is this kid he's
brand-new no one really knows him but
here's his stuff and it worked I got
here I sent out all these emails to all
his managers with the real a resume that
website all professionally done thank
God for my creative team because I can't
do this stuff I wasn't Eddie make my
website I didn't make my real I had an
amazing team of friends really talented
friends you did this for me they're
professionals
at what they do but they also happen to
be friends so let's go back as if that
sounds great a creative team but how did
you so you knew
so-and-so did website she knew so and so
did reals how many times did you meet
with them oh god rest to them the real
was a two three year process along okay
of getting clips together going through
them highlighting what what we're gonna
use what we're not gonna use I had you
know yeah I had two editors working on
my real then I had a graphic designer to
make a website which I paid for well you
know enfold but he was a friend I played
soccer with really talented guy
extremely talented people and these
people were able to make me you know
package me and it's one on a website and
make me look marketable and that's what
you have to do you have to do that
because there's too many actors out
there to just come to LA and say go to a
manager and say hey here's my here's my
head shot
I'm working on my reel right and I think
when you when you show all that it it
also sends a message that you know you
get work done or you kind of do what you
say you're going to do it's complete
right you you know yeah are your credits
are you working on you know x-men for no
maybe not but you're at least you
understand what the business is about by
doing that because you're you have to
it's a business you have to be a
marketable human being right
you have to appeal to the masses how do
you do that you have to at least have a
portfolio that kid can you know get to a
lot of people so I thought the website
would do that with a real that packages
me you know into one its clicking you
know gave them if gate it made it I mean
it's very easy for managers and agents
to access what I've done and I think
actors they don't do enough of that
so when you got here how did you get
access to those people's information
IMDB I went on IMDB Pro which you can
pay for it's like I don't know 60 bucks
a month I can't believe I'm saying this
at this is very good information actress
out there and I went yeah I'm just gonna
do it I went through you can actually
sort through on I'm you Pro and rank
that managers and agents one to there's
like twenty thousand of them and I went
through for three weeks three weeks
stayed in my apartment had a glass of
wine occasionally just to relieve the
stress and tension and went through and
sort it out whose contact info like I
have because sometimes they don't list
you know sometimes the emails are there
sometimes they're not I emailed
everybody anyway I didn't care because
my mentality was I have nothing to lose
and I went through and I emailed the top
100 managers in Los Angeles and I got
responses and a lot of them were funny
they were like we don't usually do this
but would you take a meeting with us
like yeah of course I would take a
meeting with you and I was fortunate to
take about eight meetings and got offers
from about from four people and I signed
with with one which was the best one and
this has been within how much time four
months four months how long with it was
this email and what did it say
it was one-page and he was extremely
candid and honest hey my name is Michael
Galante here's my real here's my resume
here's a website here's some photos I
would love to work with you let me know
what you think
it was extremely honest and just to the
point there was no BS I didn't really
talk about myself you know why because
the website did it
the real did it that's the beautiful
thing about a real when you have that
you don't have to talk about yourself
because once you start talking about
yourself people tune out come on I mean
we're on the street and you start
talking by yourself you hear someone
talk up it's like okay you could be
telling the truth or you could not be
telling truth you know you don't know
you have no idea
you can't fake a real it's there you
press play and those are images of you
on a show or in a commercial that's not
that's not BS so I was it was all
planned out so you said the real was
what two years in the making
yeah well no if you think about it it
was of all the time I was in New York
about five six years in the making
took all the footage compiled it into my
reels come along five minutes it's a
great reel it's funny though isn't it
six years of work into five minutes and
so what made you choose certain scenes
I'd hired a my editor Mark Odgers who's
one of the most talented people I know
in this world and he he was like use
this don't use this this is terrible
this is good we're gonna use that he
just turned it into me until it a little
little movie and that's when people
watched when I sent out to managers and
agents they're like okay okay I'm gonna
call this kid going back to that real I
hear a lot of actors saying you know
what I'm having trouble getting this
spot from this one director for this one
project whatever oh did you encounter
any of that oh oh I'm so glad you asked
let's I'm gonna be very candid about
this one of the hardest things to do as
an actor especially beginning and you're
doing student projects or independent
projects is to get footage from
directors and there were times what I
didn't receive footage I'd work two
weeks three weeks you know long days on
a project and they wouldn't give me my
footage
and I was seeing a pattern of this
especially in the first few years of
doing this and I was like oh no this is
I would send a barrage of emails phone
calls texts and be like you owe me this
is footage I did this for almost like
low to no pay what I did this for it was
experienced and for you to give me my
damn footage I would harass people oh I
would say I'm coming to your house and
I'm gonna take it off your hard drive
because they owe you that you know
directors you know I love directors but
some of them take advantage of actors
especially if they're not paying you
they're using your talent for their film
that is your work though and they owe
you that
so get your footage you deserve it you
earn it and you need to use it to show
people it's not going to do anything on
someone's hard drive nice yeah I feel
very strongly about this because I've
had lots of run-ins with directors and
that's your work I mean that is your
work get it and use it so we understand
that you have some very strong tips on
how to not just get in the business but
stay there and you talk to a lot of
actors yeah I would consult actors
beginning actors in New York as someone
that would be like how did you do this
how did you get the jay-z commercial how
did you get an agent how did you and I
would give them tips you know but the
first tip is this go get good at acting
go take a class go take multiple classes
go do improv just go get good and acting
because that's how you're gonna book
work you're gonna go into the room and
you're gonna kill an audition and that's
where you're gonna book work unless
you're a ridiculously looking
good-looking person and you just go in
and just someone wants to sleep with you
and yeah you're gonna book work doing
that too but if you really want to be a
working actor in this business
go get good so call the best teachers
call the best acting coaches and go work
on your craft the next thing is go be
marketable meaning present yourself in a
marketable way get an acting actor reel
it when you have footage how do you get
footage if you don't have an agent or a
manager go do student films this is a
perfect opportunity to go
practice what you're working on and
actually the pressure is low to know
it's like you do a student film and you
you don't do well in it guess who's
gonna watch it nobody okay
the students are gonna watch it so go
practice your craft doing you know
independent stuff um a lot of people it
just irks me when people like oh that's
a student feel I'm not gonna do that
you're not oh oh really you're not gonna
do that because who are you again like
who are you like some like working actor
who can turn down work no you're gonna
do that student film because you're not
a good actor or or maybe you are a good
actor but you still need the practice
do not turn down work it's an
opportunity you should be grateful there
are millions of actors out there who
don't do who don't work at all you know
death student film that was offered to
you that role make the most of it try
something new you know
RIT take risks oh god I just get
frustrated sometimes with actors you see
they're actors and they are turning down
work because it's there's no money
there's no money in the beginning there
is no money you're not doing this for
money you're doing this because you love
it and you want to get better and it's
inspirational you're not doing it
because you know the student film only
pays you $50 a day give me a break even
that $50 a day to to what to act awesome
ah anyway so yeah tips so go get a good
acting coach go get better at acting do
student films you know to make stuff for
your reel what else and surround
yourself surround yourself with artistic
people who are like you and love love
the art because if you surround yourself
with people who are I had like our like
mind as you you're gonna get better I
probably have I can say four or five
actor friends and all of them have the
same beliefs that I do about acting and
it's it's we do it or we die it's like I
I want to do this for the rest of my
life but there's nothing no other option
and that's I don't know when we're and
they're creative and brilliant and you
want to surround yourself with people
who are better than you or more talented
with you than you because then you get
better
rise to their level and uh yeah there's
a lot of actors I look up to you and I
aspire to be like well are there
different tips for New York actors
versus LA actors uh I think it's this
the same that my experience from being
here a little bit is there's a lot more
I don't want to say this the wrong way
in New York there's no real fake you
can't fake it in New York because you
fake it in New York you're gonna have to
leave New York because the rents higher
you know you just you can't afford to
fake it in New York you had my
experience from being in LA for the
small amount of time is that there's a
lot of LA actors who call themselves
actors who are not really actors they're
not even trying
they just call themselves actors in New
York there's a lot of actors who are our
actors who are really in classes every
single day hustling and hustling and
hustling and really trying to be
creative we're here it's a lot of people
are trying to be famous rather than
trying to work because the opportunities
here there's a lot more opportunities
here
they really are there's a lot more work
here it's one of the reasons why I moved
here a lot of theatres hear people say
that theatre here in LA is is terrible
Haru you to judge that work is work make
the most of it you know what I mean if
you're not working go join a theater
company there's a bunch of them in North
Hollywood I just art is art to me you
know and it's not all about film and
television theater is great New York
theater is some of the best art in the
world
LA theaters is fine you know it's work
what are some of the things you've done
to find different LA theater companies
oh I researched as soon as I got here I
was like well don't have a manager don't
have an agent don't really want to pay
for an acting class right now because I
know how much money go join a theater
company and from that theater company I
was cast in a play that had a great run
and it got me some reviews in LA Weekly
so that was that was great it was trust
by theater Unleashed my theater company
was a great cast great production and
it was awesome he was like a I treat it
like a fantastic acting class and an
opportunity to meet other great actors
and perform in front of people like
that's what real actors do right I want
to talk about when you go in to meet
with a casting director or a potential
agent and when they try to see you as a
certain type or role or ethnicity yeah
any stories from that that you can share
my first guest star role was last year
for Rizzoli and Isles and I was cast as
a Latino guy Alberto Santana on Rizzoli
and Isles I don't really speak much
Spanish but I can wing it and I know
some words and I made it work but you
know I think my agency in my in my my
management and I I look Latino and and I
am having an ambiguously an ethically
ambiguous look to me and I've come to
terms with that and that's fine but you
get in that room with a direct cast
director and yeah you feel judged
they're looking at your like is he
Latino enough I can see it sometimes in
their eyes like is he Hispanic enough to
play this Hispanic role of Julio or
Carlos you know so there's two sides to
that it's great that I'm getting called
in for those roles because I'll tell you
what I have a better chance at booking
Hispanic role or a non multi-ethnic role
than a white role a Caucasian role
because guess what the roles the the the
the pool for actors for just a regular
you know five eleven good-looking
Caucasian dude is a ridiculous I can't
imagine I you know I probably didn't
called it I probably wouldn't get called
in so do I have an advantage because I
have to deal with a smaller actors pool
and compete with that when that pool
absolutely but there's less mean roles
for for you know multi-ethnic ethnically
ambiguous Hispanic actors right so that
kind of sucks oh there's a flip side to
it what I'd love to be going out for
lead roles and you know studio films of
course but I don't know if that's you
know it's a business
and if you actually read a great article
last week and I think the percentage of
I'm half I'm part Asian to my mother's
Filipino and it's the the percentage it
broke down the percentage of actors and
their ethnicities in studio films and I
think it was like Caucasian was like 65
to 70 african-american was like 10% and
then like Hispanic Latino was like five
percent and then Asian was like three
point four percent and that's scary and
kind of disturbing you know and and
that's a stat that kind of goes against
what I'm trying to do right you look at
that you're like that's me so I'm up
against Khan of the studios and up
against the numbers but then you know an
hour later I was like I'm gonna fight
that I'm you know I'll push there I'll
be fine but it's kind of a scary stat to
see that you know minorities are still
not getting the opportunities that the
white people are getting well when
people ask you what you are maybe they
don't yeah but how do you fight through
that because why don't they just see you
as they want to see you and cast you in
that role right because I mean if you
look at me you might think oh this guy's
Latino when I speak I speak like a you
know like an American kid right what was
your question well I mean do I don't
what do they say to you when you walk in
the room do they say hey are you yeah I
mean what's the costume where are you
from ask where are you from I'm like I'm
from New York like no where are you from
I'm like oh well my background is so and
so and then they asked how's how's the
Spanish and I'm like you know not that
strong I'd rather be like strong too
quite strong but it's not and that it
definitely hurts me you know sometimes
because they're like well we know we
need someone that speaks Spanish so
that's why my manager is thinking of
buying me rosetta stone have you ever
just flat out said you're Latino I think
that that's what they want from you and
you want them to see you as
have you ever a couple times because
that's what they're looking for so how
am I gonna give myself you know a better
chance to get the job you have to say
stuff like that and it's not complete
lying because Filipino actually is
derived from there's a lot of Spanish
influence in the Filipino culture right
so I'm not completely lying sure yeah
what's your advice to other ethnically
ambiguous actors I know there was a
great post on BuzzFeed but it was a
comedy post about what never to ask
someone yeah that's there you're never
sure and they and they did this great
video but a lot of it there was a lot of
truth in it yeah so people like so your
your what are you and then you're just
like you just wait right the same thing
yeah I mean but that's a good thing to
they're asking that it is if they're
asking that they're interested you know
and I think that's good for TV you know
you want people go like what is that
girl what is that guy who you know
that's a good thing the same time
there's a smaller percentage of actors
who are multi-ethnic and you know
ethnically ambiguous so there's a flip
side it's good that I'm competing with a
smaller group of actors but the
opportunities are definitely less I
believe it's getting better there's no
doubt it's getting better and there's
always disclaimers on audition sides and
audition pieces at the end it says NBC
is not exclusive is is always cast from
a diverse we do not discriminate it says
that on all the audition sides it's like
not really because you're looking for a
white dude right now and yeah I go in a
lot for a Latino and um do you not then
on your
no interests oh you know roller skating
and all this stuff and then do you put
in terms of what your look is or do you
just let them guess that on their own my
manager told me something and she's like
let them let them worry about it and let
them guess you just be you you just be
who you are and they'll they'll figure
it out and if they are trying to figure
out a means are interested that's good
do you know any that's what he said
leave it to them I actually had half
Filipino half Italian on my IMDb
biography goes take that down
immediately because I think you said it
because he didn't want me to exclude
myself from Latino so that lets you know
you know they're looking for latina role
they're like what we can't take him he's
Italian and Filipino that's not what you
know let them judge you you know which
is this business is it's what it is the
casters are looking at you like not as a
person they're looking at is is he a
Latin guy for this role of Carlos is he
just that's the way it is you know cuz
it's a lot of money involved and they're
they're marked themselves to a specific
customer they really are it's just it's
just what it is it's it's it's the evil
but it's what you have to deal with as a
professional actor man in a box by Kevin
Eugene Davis is this your first leading
role no no I've had I've had other
leading leading roles in feature films
do you remember how you were offered the
role yeah actually my friend Warren Bob
who plays Sonny in the film as a friend
of mine and we worked together on a
bunch of projects couple plays a couple
other films that we've done and he
called me and he was like you know they
need a lead dropped out or they need a
lead for this film when I was like oh
really are they I mean are they
auditioning like well they're they need
somebody now I'm like really interesting
would you send me the script and the
director kind of knew of me before Kevin
knew knew of me and he sent me the
script and I read it and I was like yeah
I'd like to get involved in this is that
cool and he kind of I think he saw some
of the stuff I've done or he checked my
stuff out on eBay
something they offered me they're all
straight out by actually never audition
for it which is interesting I don't know
if I'm allowed to say that so that work
isn't great yeah yeah yeah I had a I had
a real before the most recent one and I
think he saw that and was sold that I
can play Ryan so that's how it how it
kind of went down and I went to the
table read and then I was on set and
shootings movie and where did they shoot
wilkes-barre Pennsylvania Wow I was
about two and a half hour drive from New
York City and how long were you there
ah we shot I would total of oh wow
it was like three weekends three he was
like total week nine 10 days shooting we
drive we leave the city I'm like Friday
shoot you know Friday Saturday Sunday
maybe Monday then drive back to New York
that was for about three or four
weekends in a row and when you're
preparing for your scenes are you kind
of by yourself or do you prefer to be
amongst people I like to rehearse my
scene partner to go over beats different
moments you know in the scene I do like
to be on my own to going to my own
intentions and things that I want to do
when is she even seen any funny stories
from the set that you could share oh god
I was so long ago I'm sure there you
know there were a bunch of bloopers and
mishaps obviously there's always that's
the fun on set which is funny with the
crew or you know some of the improv was
hysterical that me and Chelsea Marino
had she played my fiance Caitlin there
Kevin really let us go a few times there
was a dinner scene or drinking wine fake
wine and it was kind of sexual there was
some sexual undertones there and he let
me really go which is fun and I think we
did like maybe 13 14 takes of but it was
it was all different you know it was
great and also the scene where so Ryan
he finds drugs in this church that he's
working at he's supposed to install
security cameras in his church stumbles
upon all this cocaine
and he's like well I'm gonna sell this
you know this is the whole this is how
he gets all kind of in trouble with the
the mob and he goes to meet a drug
dealer now riot is a regular kind of
like not up and eat not not a yuppie
type per se but more of an upscale you
know comes from a good family and he's
not like a thuggish you know he doesn't
associate with drug dealers on a daily
basis so the scene where I go to meet
the drug dealer to make the drug deal
with Chelsea Katelyn my fiance was one
of my favorite scene in the film because
it's me in a diner we're meeting this
drug dealer who they picked a great
character his name is see I think in his
real life isn't he was see - don't quote
me on that but he was like this big
Hispanic tough just his like hysterical
actor great character actor and he he
was so scary and just a lot of times I
would I would try and speak to him like
you know here we have the drugs like so
how's this gonna go down and he just
wouldn't say anything at me and I'm
sitting there you know just really
scared because this is a bit weird a
shady neighborhood he could pull out a
gun in any moment we're trying to get
money out of this guy who could probably
kill us you know it's me and my
beautiful fiancee here and it made for a
very very comedic scene and I think you
I hopefully the chills are not great
Michael have you ever had a
disappointing audition that actually led
to acting work and also vice versa one
were you nailed it and you never heard
back oh god yeah the second one that you
said happens all the time to me but my
first Lauren order appearance I thought
I bombed the audition I went in there I
was nervous was my first audition for
them in New York and i reaiiy went in I
was nervous i what i I was prepared but
I was just waiting us because it's my
first time in front of these people and
I left the audition and I actually
called my my parents and I was like I
bombed it this is awful I was like
depressed for like like you know like
the next few hours like this is terrible
like why what am i doing is my first
you know here in New York trying to act
trying to you know be an actor and I
kind of call the next day and they're
like you booked they love you they will
and I didn't understand I was like what
what is this what is this business you
know and it's like they were actually
looking for a nervous young police
officer to play the role I guess that's
what I came off as so they booked me
insane and I and I was able to do he was
a principal role with Jeremy Sisto and
Anthony and ourselves my first principal
role on the TV show we're dead kills
story so from that day what is that that
must have changed your whole perception
about oh yeah life and just you don't
know you just you be prepared as much as
you can you go in these rooms and you do
your best you never know what they're
looking for because there have been
auditions when I've been so prepared
maybe even over prepared crush the
audition and they're like they are
looking for a black guy or you're you
know what they're you were not Latino
enough so you here's what you can
control in that room and this is a good
tip for actors you can only control what
you control which is your acting talent
you can't worry about how tall you are
you can't worry if your eyes are the
right color you go in there and you make
a fan you go in there and you try and do
the best work that you can you know that
that's that's all you can do and there
have been multiple times this past pilot
season I had some amazing callbacks some
of the best auditions I've had in Los
Angeles thus far and yeah in Bukit but
after I got that call for my
management's I didn't book it it
bothered me for about five minutes and I
was like I can't be upset there was
nothing else I could do there was
nothing else no other acting choices I
could have made that could have you know
got me the role or not gotten me the
role it was the best that I could do and
that was a good feeling actually it was
actually a good feeling it was like you
know what they missed out who ever you
know didn't book me it's like I did my
best and that's all it's all you can do
is your best but make sure your do
your best because you know you know when
you're not doing your best you know when
your work is like you weren't
underprepared you flubbed a line because
you weren't really off-book you got to
go in there and be a hundred percent
confident that you're giving your best
because guess what if you're not the
next guy is and that's the guy that's
gonna book the role what's being
over-prepared Oh rehearsing the scene
too much that's happened to me before
for my auditions I get an acting coach I
hire I have two acting coaches that I
work with for every single other should
I go on and there are times when I go in
there and and I'm ready to work with
them and I'm over prepared to rehearsed
where it's not organic you know you
could that there's being off-book is
great you know but being off-book to the
point where you're not anticipating or
you're anticipating the other person's
lines is no bueno
it's got to be organic so you know if I
read that script a billion times and did
the sightseeing with you a billion times
when I get to the audition it's gonna
look robotic it's not gonna be fresh and
fun and it's what they want you know
they want a fresh fun compelling scene
so if I throw out a line could you omit
mcwhat over-prepared was down like like
honey how was work
no it's more like if you said that line
to me and I responded in organically
like say it honey it was great oh that
doesn't work because you don't even get
to finish your sentence that's being a
prepared okay do you know what he means
yes good analogy okay yeah so in those
early days when you made that decision
had your conversation with your parents
was it easier to book acting work or
modeling work or two different animals
modeling work primarily because I had a
modeling agent before I had an acting
agent in New York so they really get me
out and get me print jobs and some some
commercial stuff and that paid the bills
and that was a blessing because that was
that gave me the ability to go take an
acting class and not wait tables you
know it gave me time to go work on the
scene with someone instead of waiting
tables so that would that was that was a
blessing and the modeling work is it's
easier it's there's no lines you're
trying on clothes
you're looking pretty it's not it's not
really that hard
the acting work is the stuff that takes
time and effort and is a lifelong
journey
whereas modeling is you better look good
you don't look good or you look right
for some campaign or you don't you know
it's very kind of you go in there and
they book here they don't it's not you
know it's not acting
are there different modeling looks for
LA versus New York I don't know if
there's normally in LA I haven't really
done any mom
I booked a corona print ad which is
which was cool but I feel there's more
modeling in New York and that's one
thing that kind of sucks about LA but I
came here to act not here to model you
know I didn't really go to New York to
model the first place I happened to book
a few modeling jobs and some commercial
stuff which is great but I didn't move
to New York to be a model how did that
happen
New York what the modeling um this is a
secret I was a working fit model for
seven years in New York City I don't
know if you know what a fit model is
people automatically think it's like
fitness modeling now you're shredded
you're you're lifting weights and you're
on covers of magazines so a fit model is
someone your shirt for instance who's it
designed by whatever yeah Karen clothing
right so when Karen clothing made that
that blouse oh that shirt they before
they can actually produce it and put it
in stores they have to fit in on
somebody okay so let's say gap made this
t-shirt I used to work for gap so I can
say that gap made this t-shirt right so
if they want to sell it they have to try
it on a fit model size 32 about 511 170
pounds and they have to try every single
piece of clothing on that standard fit
model
I was lucky for some reason apparently
jeans fit me perfectly
and and I'm just I'm just like
apparently a perfect size 32 so I was
able to do that with a bunch of a bunch
of fit modeling clients in New York
which paid a ridiculous amount of money
so I was able to pay my bills doing that
very lucky very lucky how did you get
that gig I wet my agency was like you
ever do fit my
I'm like I'm not really that Jack
they're like no dude it's not about
Fitness it's like you try and close Mike
okay I got my first my first client plug
jeans and they hired me and was paying
me by the hour a ridiculous about it my
name is steady because it's like they
look at the jeans they don't fit they're
like what's wrong with these jeans I'm
like well they suck they suck here they
suck here this doesn't fit this doesn't
fit okay
they take the gene they send it to China
get it fixed adjusted send it back all
right
meet Michael again try the jean again
and they did that with every single
piece of clothing so it was steady work
it's not many people know about the
industry but it's and some of the you
know makes the most money the plus-size
girls forget it they were getting paid
$300 an hour so how does someone find
those jobs go find a modeling agency in
New York that does that
I actually was lucky to stumble upon one
and I had good people working for me so
they really get me at one point I had
about nine or ten pretty top clients
using me for uh for denim and for four
tops mostly denim apparently my ass is
perfect for jeans uh I don't know man it
was really awkward my first when I was
doing the fit modeling cuz it's just
like they're like touching you it's like
really this happens really yeah I feel
like a piece of meat absolutely oh
absolutely but you know it's I had fun
with it I just I had fun with it and
they're paying me so I was like shut
your mouth and you let them you know if
they touch your knee in a weird area it
makes you laugh you deal with it right
but then eventually you progressed and
they wanted to see all of you yeah yeah
absolutely
oh well you look decent in tops too so I
did that I don't know I guess I should
thank my parents they gave me a perfect
size yeah okay thank you mama